welcome back finley acura and the valley
auto mall prides themselves on
exceptional
customer service take a look
[Music]
when it comes to accurate dealerships
finley acura and the valley auto mall
well they're kind of the champs travis
congratulations on
eight years in a row the dealership of
distinction awards tell everyone what
that means
absolutely so dealership and distinction
is acura's highest honor it's based on
primarily on customer satisfaction
after the sale it is a top tier award
but to me what's even more impressive is
some of your yelp reviews your google
reviews and i actually brought some here
when i get your thoughts on a couple of
these here okay first one it comes from
colin five-star rating colin actually
came here from l.a
and says my family and i have been
leasing from acura for a little over
seven years now
and i've always had a great experience
with the team carmine
five stars i just bought a 2022 mdx
from finley acura this is my first
review i had to share
because i had a great car buying
experience and then crystal
five-star review she's been an accurate
owner for 14 plus years
and doesn't see yourself changing from
this dealership anytime soon
what do you say when you get reviews
like this thank you
that's what it's all about customer
satisfaction and that's what we're here
to
uh to provide great customer
satisfaction can you uh can you show me
around
absolutely travis i'm a car guy so to be
standing next to an acura
nsx this is a beautiful piece of
machinery tell everyone more about this
car
so the nsx is going to be acura's
supercar
but with design to be able to be an
everyday driver
hold on so someone is gonna they're
gonna buy this and they're gonna go to
albertsons and get their groceries in
this car
what's the top speed in a car like this
191 miles per hour
this one's actually perfect for vegas
casino white pearl
[Music]
you buy a new or used vehicle from
finley acura your first oil change
is free travis what are some of the
other service incentives that you guys
offer
so for the life of the vehicle we'll
also offer free smog checks
we'll do them right here at our location
as well as free car washes
and while you're waiting for your
vehicle to be serviced you know we have
all of our amenities inside like
fountain drinks cappuccino
coffee machines cold water whatever you
may need
big screen tvs and couches to make
yourself comfortable if someone has to
have a long-term repair done here do you
guys offer loaner vehicles we do we
actually have a fleet of acuras as well
as
enterprise cars jc so i showed you the
nsx couldn't let you leave without
checking out acura's newest design
the mdx this is a gorgeous what midsize
suv
absolutely now how does the online
buying process work it's very simple
pick out the vehicle we'll work out all
the details in terms of the financing
we'll bring the vehicle to you along
with all the paperwork for uh signing
it's easy travis we covered it all today
thank you so much for having us out here
we appreciate it thank you
you can call finley acura at 702
702-982-4100 for more information or
visit
findlayacura.com mercedes over to you